la poste de la rue du 7ème
arrondissement il est 17h j'envoie un
pelé matic reconnu
non
je le dois
donc on vient de paris va-t-il environ
une heure
cette lettre nous allons maintenant la
suivre tout au long des 15 km de
parcours qui vont l'amener à la poste de
la rue cler
première étape la gare de l'est à un
aiguillage automatique va orienter notre
tv
ce tube qui possède une aspérité un
grand il déclenche électriquement
l'aiguillage
direction la bourse
le centre vital il y as entend
exactement il y naquit le réseau en 1866
3 km 400 km en 1966 400 km le cube
souterrain qui quadrillent la capitale
huit millions de missives transportés
chaque année
la bourse est un centre de prise chaque
jour des milliers de lettres passe de
marne
le flux qui porte à l'étude c'est l'air
pulsé comprimé raréfier le voici dans
l'atelier de force motrice
il y en a sept dans tout paris ici trois
machines 265 chevaux chacune pull
solaire sans arrêt vers les 15 centres
de force qui le distribue aux quatre
coins de la capitale
si le curseur se bloque et l'accident
est peu fréquent on envoie une colonne
d'air et en fonction du temps de
compression et de détente
on peut localiser à 10 mètres près le
tube obstrué 17h35 notre message c'est
glisse dans l'entrelacement il réel de
cette province et pérenne de tubes et de
tuyaux le central 103 rue de grenelle
point de correspondance la lettre
changera de tubes et repart vers le
poste de la rue cler paris 7
17 à 45 le message arrive
un quart d'heure plus tard le petit
télégraphiste déposera au pénal